go ahead Mary ask it why did you kill my
mother
because I hate you I've dreamed my whole
life about saving her this is why you
became the flash
there's no choice here Barry you have to
do this
you have to change the past
run Barry run save mom at what cost
oh my god
cannot be stopped when your room is
being erased from existence
right here it's me mom that's Barry
hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
going to be a breakdown of the last
flash trailer there's some shared
footage with the legends of tomorrow
trailer so I addressed that too there
were also some leaks from the set so I'm
gonna save a few things for after the
episode so let's start with the big
stuff first the reverse-flash
looks like he's going to reveal to Barry
what happened in the future that made
him hate him so much that made the
reverse-flash hate Barry that speech he
had last week at the beginning of the
episode the monologue he opened the
episode with was all about getting
things back that were taken from him his
life his family everything he knew that
just sounds like something you would say
if somebody changed the past and erased
existence as you knew it amongst the
different iterations of the eobard
thawne reverse-flash usually he hates
Barry just because Barry keeps stopping
him from being a criminal even though
most iterations paint him as this super
genius from the 25th century he has
something of an inferiority complex with
Barry Allen Barry Allen is the flash
that history admires the most and in the
reverse flash just feels like he's never
going to live up to that so he just
really pissed off there's also an older
version of the origin story you know
whereby he sees that he's predestined to
become a criminal and it drives him
crazy
that's just like another take on the
character the show seems like it's
changing things in the name of
simplicity it's much easier to
understand that he hates Barry Allen
because Barry Allen took his life from
him announcing like the choice he's
giving Barry in this episode is to help
him or face the consequences and it
looks like the consequences are some
sort of apocalyptic event that the
reverse-flash sets off in present day
like this big tear in the sky here we
see Martin Stein and Ronnie Raymond in
the trailer so we know firestorm is
going to be there but if you jump over
to the legends of tomorrow trailer you
can actually see Hawkgirl looking at the
sky in a very similar looking scene
supposedly we're going to get some sort
of like legends of tomorrow moment in
the finale so it makes sense that
Hawkgirl is on this same street looking
up at the sky like Lee gave this big
tear in the sky we also see Harrison
wells approaching his time sphere in
this episode in the flash finale and in
the legends of tomorrow trailer so it
just it makes sense that there's some
shared footage between these two
episodes all this legends of tomorrow
footage that's from the first episode
obviously we're not going to see that
for a while this scene here looks like
they're going to talk to wells in his
prison
as you can see Eddie's in the background
here so he hasn't left team flash for
good yet there's a lot of questions I
said like what his character might be
doing in season two whether he's a
villain or he just kind of on the outs
with the flash and then here we get
Barry going back into the past so
obviously we do see that he meets his
mother the interesting thing is that
this flash looks like a different
version than the Barry Allen that we've
been watching it looks like the original
version of the flash that we keep seeing
in the flashbacks the one that was
changed when eobard thawne killed
Barry's mother cisco has that voice over
where he said he's being erased that
doesn't necessarily mean that he's
talking about this flash he could be
talking about characters in present-day
that kind of comes as Ronnie Raymond is
messing with this here there's a lot of
theories that jason rusch could be
replacing Ronnie Raymond in firestorm
but none of that's confirmed there's a
number of ways that could go down here
we see our version of Barry Allen the
one that we be seeing this season with a
different emblem that's going to be an
easy way to tell which Barry you're
looking at the Barry from before or the
Barry from now so just pay attention to
what color the flash symbol on his chest
is even though this trailer is kind of
touchy-feely this conversation with his
mother like whatever goes down in this
scene is going to be one of the most
important moments from the season the
lesson that this flash hasn't learned
yet that our version of Barry Allen
hasn't learned is that some things you
just you can't change from the past
there are certain fixed points in time
Joe had that speech like really early on
it was in like the first one or two
episodes I think where he said learn to
accept the things that I can't change is
right out of the comic books it's in the
animated movie - the animated Justice
League flashpoint paradox movie Barry
Allen's mother doesn't die and
everything goes darkest timeline the
real question though is is you know
Barry goes back in time does he end up
saving his mother does he end up
changing the past and doing something
terrible to the future just because he
goes back doesn't mean he's going to
save his mother it seems like he is like
that's what you want you to think but
that doesn't mean that that's going to
happen by all accounts most of the
characters we see in this season will
return for next season it just you know
a lot of that character dynamics will
change so even if Ronnie Raymond ends up
dying Jason Rusch replaces him as
firestorm with Martin Stein it could be
because of something that organically
happens in present day like Ronnie
Raymond trying to save them from that
big Cataclysm there's so much that we
don't know about how the show is
treating mechanics
firestorm like how does Jason Rusch
become part of the matrix that's all
just speculation but it's it's basically
the back door to killer frost to Caitlin
snow just going off the deep end there's
been a lot of talk of danielle Panabaker
confirming killer frost I do think that
she'll be something of an antagonist in
season two in the most logical ways for
that to happen would be for her to have
a falling out over the death of Ronny or
because the past was changed in Ronnie
never survived the particle accelerator
explosion you guys can let me know what
you think how do you think that caitlin
snow is going to become her killer frost
you know her villain character Carlos
Valdez the actor the play Cisco also
said that the episode would deal with
some of the vibe mythology from the
comics so if you're big fan of vibe
there will be some vibe related stuff in
the episode he didn't specify what
though just remember that some people on
the flash TV show get their powers from
tech some of them get them because their
metahumans usually it's the smarter
people that make their own tech so Cisco
being a tech person if he's going to be
vibe he's probably gonna make himself a
bunch of tech just to do some prep I
would recommend that you guys check out
the Justice League animated movie
flashpoint paradox it's really fun it's
not what they're doing on the TV show
it's but it's slightly related it's all
about eobard thawne finding a way to
erase barry without erasing himself so
really big reminder flash finale next
week be sure to subscribe to get my
video will either get characters from
legends of tomorrow in that episode or
like a promo at the end of it like some
sort of legends of tomorrow moment so be
sure to watch all the way through the
episode and the end credits once we find
out what's going on with all the
characters I'll do a season 2 video with
you know some predictions and then also
doing character videos for legends of
tomorrow all that kind of stuff it's
going to be a lot of fun so in case you
guys haven't seen it you can click here
for the legends of tomorrow trailer and
you can click here for yesterday's QA
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you